[Music]
my body feels like when I'm Dan he's
killed my little ol Claim going below
fill my brain under there boom boom boom
boom
[Music]
my name son
I'm a duck benefit I saw me she and I -
it
I'm piled to beat up yes I'm totally
beat up
no why because I hit the negative around
me I grew up thinking I popped first
before I think it still it's telling me
American Sign Language is still that can
communicate with thought with our hand
when people speak up he was fighting for
him right now
I'm trying to sort a Dan Trent for a
still site link with dancing come on get
it never see the foot
[Music]
music make me feel high be my famous
ball
karma on
[Music]
I thought hunch there you go his name
I'm Hanna beat years ago didn't cut my
brother any wave function and Dan backup
dancer for on the ship when I was taking
I taught my billet out of damn there's
name kita great on stage we can camp
teacher walking with Robin
[Music]
dub people one don't want to listen to
music true people said no can't duck you
can't get anything somebody calls my hot
because I feel it
boom boom sup sunken sales that I took
that Hawking had to work with all can
spawn to get these I'm an Internet help
me here a little big
not everything not all you know how I
listen to meet you
so I put my hand on the speaker bill
with remember I let's be open again then
again that what nuts sudden I'm where
I'm leaders again again damn then net
band put it together and one I'm what
are people think that I cannot do pick
it up so pricey make perfect right
[Music]
[Applause]
can you read you two so we are an
instrument we are a part of their band
and then you're providing and opening up
so many doors for deaf people who have
already been fighting for this access
daily the first time I went to a concert
and I saw them - interpreting on stage I
was like that's when I was like I
understand how the Deaf culture can
really be involved with the concerts and
be able to go to festivals and really
appreciate and enjoy that
just like the hearing community at the
angel for I walk my because I bad knew
my inner ears I got sick high school
yeah they put me in a deaf program
stretch me yeah I squash long winning
and still and we need up people bit cool
I'm sorry I kidney I've been happy wow I
could come to the K I can understand I'm
not alone anymore but what if I we sit
down my dad so my dad was too dense to
chew he died before I was born so I
would never fall he's against it okay
my family show me a finding of him
and I'm like wow so good I wanna be like
that ah
what's motivating me from cheese
it's because I want to play God but when
it up event run up to the world kid
new kind of dancing they never spring
yeah people feel kinetically just on
death not fine understand we're not
going to my dance class we have loud
beef of dancing because we had to have
feel the beat so yeah it was really fun
because you could have a feeling up to
your body so it's like hate again
my dream in the future I want to do
quality was fine for other audience I
was going on backup dancer for stinker
or rapper but behind I danced for him in
far lately but I want I just want some
help being a role model when the deaf
community see should never give up
showing the world that we can
this video is part of a larger series on
the deaf community here are some of the
incredible people featured in this
series
subscribe to catch all of these amazing
stories on this season of untold America
and let us know what community we should
cover next
[Music]